hello the internet ungallant uh we're in
Texas with online legends the slow mo
guys you ready yeah I think it's time
for the slow mode hammer time mirror
mirror on the wall what's the highest
frame rate camera of all so this is a
hundred twenty thousand frames a second
oh oh so cool nearly four million of us
had our mind shattered by the vending
glass so why does the hammer cause a
ripple in the mirror before it smashes
in actual fact every time glass is hit
it ripples but it happened so quickly we
can't see it with the naked eye glass is
hard and brittle and easy to break but
even so it's still considered as a
material which is elastic this is
because it has an amorphous molecular
structure an amorphous structure has
more space for the atoms to move around
as a result the glass is slightly
flexible meaning that it's able to bend
when Dan's hammer first hits it
however the glass isn't flexible enough
to withstand the force of the hammer and
so rather than bend back into shape it
shatters
ironically the mirror didn't see it
coming